déchirée on va parler du coming out à la
télé est il risqué puisque hier soir il
y avait les missions soirée pyjama a
présenté par yann barthès sur tmc et
elle était consacrée à vincent de dien
et l'humoriste devait réaliser une série
de défis il est entouré plein de
complices donc notre ami jérôme
commandeur et hier il a fait de
nombreuses allusions toute la soirée à
son homosexualité tout au long de la
série et voilà ces essais on a tout le
monde a dit voilà il a fait son coming
out voilà hier soir à l'antenne alors
justement regarder petit mac reka et
vous allez me dire est-ce qu'il y en a
de plus en plus de gens voilà qui font
leur coming out comme on dit j'aime pas
trop ce mot là à moi voilà je trouve que
je trouve c'est un peu péjoratif
voilà allons tenir qu'il ya laurent
wauquiez aussi qu'il l'a fait il ya
quelques temps là dans le parisien il ya
christophe beaugrand
il ya même voilà mounir mahjoubi qui
l'avait fait avant une de paris match
regarde hier soir tmc proposait à ses
téléspectateurs une nouvelle émission
intitulée soirée pyjama au tour de
l'humoriste vincent de dien une émission
de sketches de parodies dans laquelle le
comédien s'est livré à plusieurs
reprises à des confidences sur son
homosexualité
est ce que tu veux et allongée oui oui
et c'est toujours avec une pointe 7ème
et allongé pour parler parler on peut
parler avant c'était une chose qu'il n'a
jamais cachés ni dans ses chroniques
nino et spectacles mais que certains
semblent avoir découvert hier soir
vincent de diané guèye et à en croire
les messages de quelques internautes ces
révélations et l'engagement politique il
semble avoir pris n'a pas plu à tout le
monde
enfin la discrimination positive permet
encore aux gays de dire en toute
occasion qu'ils veulent coucher en
permanence avec qui leur plaît le
déchaînement que ce serait si un
hétérosexuel faisait de même émission
tellement nul et pas drôle avec un
vincent de dien obligé de rappeler qu'il
est homo toutes les cinq minutes que la
famille classique c'est nul et
réactionnaire énorme naufrage des
mauvais mec même didier lestrade un
journaliste et militant lgbt s'est
opposé aux comédiens qui prétend qu'il
est plus difficile de faire son coming
out quand on est comédien une
déclaration qui semble avoir beaucoup
agacé le journaliste faire son coming
out lors qu'on est acteur est encore
plus difficile
ah oui et le boulanger du coin alors
selon vous le coming out à la télévision
est il risqué
alors c'est une question concours vous
apposez qu'on vous pose également
alors c'est vrai voilà que moi j'aime
pas le voile je vous le redis je n'aime
pas le mot coming out est ce que vous
pensez que c'est risqué parce qu'on
parle en fait de la déclaration de
vincent de dinky à qui a énervé de
didier lestrade
voilà qui a d'ailleurs didier lestrade
qui est celui qui a inspiré le
magnifique film 120 battements par
minute et c'est vrai quoi ils disaient
voilà c'est aussi difficile
c'est plus difficile de faire son coming
out quand on est artiste quand on est
comédien alors est ce que il est risqué
de le faire à la télé vous gérez se dit
non non c'est pas plus difficile quand
on est artiste s'est pas encore facile
et je le déplore il faut que ce soit
naturel ou qu'ils aient aucune polémique
mais quand on est artiste on est quand
même dans un milieu entre guillemets
privilégiée même si à l'image qu'on
renvoie c'est plus facile effectivement
c'est bien trouvé le boulanger du coin
les gens qui sont dans des milieux où
hélas ça pose encore problème c'est
beaucoup plus risqué et pour moi même si
c'est un tout petit peu risqué il faut
le faire parce que les artistes donnent
l'exemple d'accord parce qu'il faut le
faire alors exactement alors lire qu'on
a compilé toutes les allusions de
vincent de dien regarder dans la soirée
hello brad pitt
colling
enjoy stinks comme comme atom
régulièrement yann je te demanderai de
prendre la température
à l'aide de cet accessoire est fait est
ce que tu veux tu allongée oui oui c'est
toujours avec tu me pose cette question
oui mais allongée à pour parler parler
oui on peut parler avant site e
j'ai une anecdote gênant pour vincent
avec qui j'ai longtemps essayé
d'entretenir un flirt qui s'y est
toujours refusée et qui par contre est
très intéressé par mon fils et ça ça
m'énerve c'est vrai que je mets des
coeurs à chaque fois qu'il met une photo
c'est vrai
alors voilà donc c'est vrai il ya plein
de gens qui ont réagi là dessus vous
ambitionnez vous dit non
regardez bien tout ce beau petit ben oui
non mais un peu un peu comme gilles
voilà c'est un milieu quand même
favorisé on à la carte c'est même plutôt
bien vu d'ailleurs d'être homosexuel
part dans le milieu il est bien vu est
pas parce que je n'ai pas cessé un peu
si tu pasqua groupe dans trois
arrondissements de paris déjà mis de
côté parce que je pense laisser les
termites ça fait toujours broncher je
trouve quand tu es un peu non eh ben
c'est ce que je pense à toi tu peut-être
ne trouve pas ça mais moi je vois c'est
quand même plus facile de dire que tu es
gay ça fait bon choix que quand il était
au dessus parce qu'alors il ya ya un
journaliste voilà quand j'en souffrais
j'avais été un grand journaliste qui est
un journaliste et un gros journée ce qui
veut dire est ce qu'un hétérosexuel fait
son coming out
non c'est un signe de respect de
considérer qu'il n'y ait pas besoin de
de faire son coming out pour un gay il
ne devrait pas avoir besoin de le faire
voilà à wizz allemand oui il a raison ce
serait rien de formidable acteur de leur
mieux où il n'y aurait pas de récit ce
mesure a rien là où évidemment c'est
risqué de faire à la télévision
et contrairement à ce que dit gilles tu
te trompe quand on le fait dans une
friperie vie privée et qu'on n'est pas
artiste répond barona on à sa famille
qu'il faut le faire et c'est compliqué
mais là évidemment quand on fait comme
ça à la télévision
ça veut dire qu'à un deux trois ou
quatre noms de personnes qui vont le
voir dans un pays qui malgré tout est
encore un petit peu parfois homophobes
ça veut dire que dès le lendemain au
delà des insultes twitter et bien dans
la rue tu peux être confronté à des gens
en fait je veux dire un truc qui est
horrible c'est exactement quand tu fais
ça c'est comme eh ben c'est comme si
tout d'un coup tu devenais par exemple
noir pour des gens qui sont racistes tu
arrives dans la rue et eut explosé à ce
que tu es et donc évidemment que c'est
très dangereux
moi j'étais très heureux et je remercie
a beaucoup j'ai été très heureux de me
libérer dans cette émission je
paramètres uqam en 3 secondes
ce qui est sûr c'est que derrière je
n'imaginais pas je ne l'imaginais pas ce
que je vivrai tous les jours c'est vrai
en moyenne c'est 50 50 s et vous
qu'est-ce qui s'abat moi un moyen de ces
50 sms par jour que je pourrais vous
montrer avec ta mère devrait avoir honte
sales [ __ ] fils jean toute la journée
va te faire ceux venus des trucs
horribles ça c'est toute la journée deux
fois dans la rue lui faisons jamais
d'ailleurs une faculté à gré c'est dans
la rue je vous ai appelé très gentiment
derrière et à chaque fois vous répondez
vous êtes un amour une fois nous fait
sortir d'un taxi qui m'a sorti manu
militari
c'est très violent avec sa c4 du rize
image horrible qu'on veut pas moi et
voilà et mathieu je sais pas vraiment
que vous aviez autant de deux sms tout
et souvent je fais des captures aux
publics est ce que je pourrais en faire
et qu est ce que vous vous dites moi tu
as more est ce que ça vous touche vous
répond franchement oui évidemment que ça
touche évidemment que ça touche et que
ça fait du mal et ce qui me fait le plus
de mal aujourd'hui c'est de me rendre
compte à quel point d'abord à quel point
je n'imaginais pas de mettre un tel
visage sur l'homophobie et je m'en
excuse pour tous les gens qui vivent en
province et tout et c'est vrai que je ne
vivais pas puisque comme personne ne
savait j'étais dans mon petit monde
parisien donne dans une belle bulle je
ne me rendais pas compte à quel point
c'était difficile à quel point c'est
compliqué à vivre à quel point j'ai peur
parfois quand je rentre le sort du
parking et tout parce que parce que
c'est compliqué on a peur de se faire
examiner c'est vrai que je vous le dis
je le jure et mathieu voilà c'est
vraiment mon pote
voilà on est on est très proche et c'est
vrai que je vois mathieu et encore plus
en ce moment-même blainville ces
derniers jours il est il en flip voilà
il m'appelle 15 fois par un jour le soir
il a toujours peur quand il sort dans la
rue quand il va dans son parking
il a peur d'être suivie de se faire
agresser et c'est vrai que voilà et
c'est une menace que je me dis que sur
les 500 qui envoient des menaces dans la
semaine il y en a bien un un jour un fou
donc il va m'attendre devant et qui
pourra me faire très mal
et la seule chose que j'aimerais
demander vous avez peur mathieu là où je
ronge au jour le jour vous avez peur
aujourd'hui oui c'est vrai que c'est
vrai on est mort dit oui alors j'ai pas
les moyens j'en ai pas envie je suis pas
une star d'avoir d'avoir un garde du
corps et tout ça si j'en avais les
moyens je vous promets que je ris je
prendrai quelqu'un parce que je sais
qu'un jour ça va m'arriver c'est
condamnable
le jour je me ferais écrasé dans la rue
si tu veux le fait qu'ils soient
condamnables escreet horrible
aujourd'hui en plus c'est que dans un
pays où on autorise aujourd'hui les gens
le font à visage découvert ils marquent
prénom michel machin leurs photos et te
dise sale [ __ ] va te faire machin ça les
réseaux sociaux comment se fait-il que
autant de haine soit autorisée sur les
réseaux sociaux le sujet et pour vous
répondre
oui effectivement j'ai peur et à chaque
fois je vous appelle d'ailleurs merci
vous répondre à chaque fois mais oui
effectivement je vis dans la peur depuis
deux ans je n'imaginais pas un jour à
mon âge vivent dans la peur et je
comprends tout ce que vivent les gens
je m'en excuse d'ailleurs de ne pas
l'avoir compris avant égoïstement dont
puis c'est très dur alors il y en a
d'autres qui l'ont fait on se rappelle
bien sûr de frédéric lopez s'était donc
nous il est une visite et une de ces
émissions qui produisait vont penser
qu'il faut qu'il faut le faire que c'est
risqué
plutôt que c'est inscrit regardez bras
frederico on sait que les histoires de
mes invités me touche et et votre
histoire elle me touche particulièrement
c'est pourquoi est ce que j'ai vécu la
même chose pendant très longtemps j'ai
eu peur j'ai peur de cette homosexualité
que je ressentais et au fond aujourd'hui
je suis quelqu'un qui accepte tout le
monde le sait autour de moi je n'ai
jamais parlé publiquement et j'en
parlerai jamais d'ailleurs mais je
voulais vous dire que uniquement parce
que des enfants et des adolescents dans
ce pays qui se suicident parce qu'ils se
ressemblent ça et uniquement parce que
vous le faites à visage découvert j'ai
choisi d'en parler publiquement
aujourd'hui pour la seule fois de ma vie
je sais que ça va surprendre beaucoup de
gens mais c'est parce que vous
m'inspirez beaucoup je trouvais très
très très courageux et donc c'est
l'authenticité ça secret du bonheur
alors jean michel vous avez dit tout à
l'heure je vous la chose je être être
homo était une mode sinon je me suis
exprimé hier c'était un peu comme sur la
vigne carte un peu c'était peut-être
plus facile mais c'est peut-être une
vaste connerie j'en sais rien je pensais
même pas celle qu'on arrivait dossier ce
que disent et mathieu et j'ai envie de
me ranger derrière réponse les opinions
et mathieu lui a répondu tout à l'heure
il est un bien répondu trois
arrondissements et a dit mathieu france
moi je vais vous dire je fais des
livraisons le matin les jeunes sont
facilités à me parler parce que je suis
en bleu de travail et ils viennent me
parler et parfois ils de idy moi j'aime
bien lui j'aime bien lui à chaque fois
je m'engueule avec les gens parce qu'ils
me disent ouais loto si j'aime bien le
guet mais ce n'est pas voulu dire parce
que si même moi je le dis oui je suis en
train de décharger meiway l'autre des
fois il dit n'importe quoi le paie des
impôts tu parles comme ça c'est ça que
c'est comme ça il faut arrêter que c'est
con à lui nous refait la scène quand ils
sont mouillés que great
c'était que je te met une aubergine
vanessa d'ajouter aux gens à arrêter de
me parler de lui comme ça si c'est
matthieu delormeau seul matthieu
delormeau et pour le coming out quand je
dis c'est souvent pourquoi c'est
douloureux parce que quand vous regardez
bien tout ce qu'ils font qui cave ou qui
font leur coming out c'est parce que je
m'arrête pas là c'est parce qu'ils la
carrière allait fait ouais donc début
ils disent rien n'est vrai mais je suis
ça de ces risques et c'est nécessaire
aussi soutenir si nécessaire c'est moi
je pense que c'est vraiment nécessaire
vraiment désolé mais les gens le fou
quand leur carrière et bien fait alors
il ya les mairies que je suis tombé des
nues je serai pas à tout ça frédéric
lopez je ne savais pas il avoue je ne
sais pas je t shirt ou maria pas fou
mais à montrer que c'est pas un petit
reportage où tu fais beaucoup je dis
comme je le pense il a reconnu qu'il
était gay l'a fait son coming out mais
je parlais que mes mots certains
culpabiliser ceux qui jamais ses marchés
au monde a jamais dit qu'ils
s'occupaient veulent pas dire il l'a
fait dans ça ne sortira pas d'ici avec
michel cymes et derrière donc dans le
parisien pourquoi vous n'en avez jamais
vous dites donc j'en ai jamais parlé à
mes parents c'est parce que c'était
parce que c'est fait parce que moi même
j'ai découvert mon nom c'est mon
homosexualité a tardivement joue à dire
dont vingt deux ans j'étais déjà parti
de chez eux donc je n'ai pas les
embarrasser avec ça et puis côtes dès
que j'ai eu
on va dire qu'un ami réguliers ils ont
très vite compris ils ont accepté ya
jamais eu aucun problème
michel je vous rappelle qu'en mai et
demi est un des rares à faire mon coming
out sur scène j'ai fait mon coming out
dans les joutes à 90 à une époque où peu
de gens le faisait j'ai ressenti un
gentil c'est dans la pièce enfin j'ai
jamais voulu être un porte parole
alors vous maxime galy vous dit non vous
dites qu'il faut pas le faire non à part
réveillée effectivement les homophobes
sur les réseaux sociaux mais lorsqu'on
voit des ruquier qui l'évoquent sur
scène et qui ont aujourd'hui la guérilla
extraordinaire à la télévision même marc
olivier fogiel et qui a l'air
extrêmement épanouie dans la presse il
en parle sans aucun problème avec ses
fils en temps réel de fer en revanche ça
reste un choix personnel soit une
obligation mais oui absolument
ainsi tu le vis mal faut le trio zira
dernier mot oui et un dernier mot parce
que est vraiment plus je le dis avec
avec tendresse parce que j'aime beaucoup
vincent de diane
dîner souvent avec lui il a un talent
fou en revanche si hier j'ai trouvé que
leur humour était un petit peu trop
parisien justement et quand pour rire il
sort ce qu'on appelle vulgairement à
plug bon je dirai pas où ça se met mais
vous allez on imagine que ce soit dans
le nez je suis pas sûr que pour la cause
et pour tout ça c'était très bien en
prime time ce genre de vannes là ça
c'est le petit truc en plus mais bon
voilà écouter en tout cas ça ça a bien
marché si l'on fait un million cent
mille téléspectateurs